wir schauen auf den berühmtesten
scharfschützen der welt send a name well
i er kämpfte als freiwilliger gegen den
esm irak kälte aus mehreren kilometern
entfernung einen terroristen jetzt war
olli freiwillig im krieg in der ukraine
und was er dort erlebt hat das hat uns
erzählt
will trifft exklusiv den weltbesten
sniper
es ist ein treffen mit dem derzeit
berühmtesten sniper spitzname wha lee
bekannt rund um die welt wegen seines
einsatzes im ukraine krieg der kanadier
der früher als scharfschütze in
afghanistan und im irak kämpfte stellt
sich zweieinhalb monate lang gegen die
russiche invasoren armee und wurde zur
internet sensation
zunächst entstand der mythos als
tödlichste scharfschütze der welt dann
meldete moskaus propagandamaschine
seinen tod bei feuergefechten in mario
pohl doch volley ist inzwischen
zurückgekehrt nach quebec bild reporter
herbert bauernebel trifft den sniper
exklusiv
ich bin ein guter soldat als
ausländischer kämpfer gegen eins habe
ich dinge gemacht die ich verfluche ich
war in afghanistan als scharfschütze ich
habe viele kampfsituationen erlebt also
ich bin ein guter scharfschütze kein
zweifel ich bin nicht der beste weil der
beste scharfschütze existiert nicht
er führt uns zu einer kleinen holzhütte
im wald
davor knistert schon ein lagerfeuer
als scharfschütze soll man sich an
seinen zielen nähern ohne gesehen zu
werden deshalb lernen wir wie wir uns am
besten tarnen so können wir von einem
sicherheitsabstand schießen was nahe
genug am ziel dran ist
es ist nicht klar ist von 800 metern zu
schießen aber es ist der beste weg die
mission zu erfüllen
ende april kehrt er zurück nach lübeck
er weiß dass er der feuerwehrmann des
krieges beim löschen des größten brandes
zu beginn der russen invasion helfen
konnte nicht nur an der front sondern
auch beim training der freiwilligenarmee
in seiner kleinen hütte entspanne er
jetzt öfters aus zuerst fürchtete wohl
dass er es nicht mehr genießen könne da
das waldstück jenen der grauenhaften 10
in der ukraine ähnlich sieht immer
wieder denkt er an die zivilisten die
inmitten der häuserkämpfe und dem
artilleriefeuer in kellern hockten die
angst die tränen
nicht weit von mir gab es feuer und
rauch es ist schwierig das zu
beschreiben aber es hat nach krieg
gerochen ein dunkler geruch der geruch
des todes links von mir lag ein ukraine
ohne beine sein körper war total
zerschlagen er war tot
selbstverständlich man hätte für ihn
nichts mehr machen können aber er war
mir so nah nur fünf meter entfernt
der freiwilligen soldat der sonst als
computer programmierer arbeitet ist
überzeugt davon auch wenn er einen
zermürbungskrieg aus schützengräben
heraus im donbass und anderen
kriegsfronten erwartet dass die ukraine
gewinnen werden
ukraine kämpfen nicht weil sie es wollen
sondern weil sie ihr land schützen
wollen das finde ich großartig
wo kommt der name ronny heer mein name
ist oliver olli fi auf französisch in
afghanistan übrigens sie dachten ich bin
afghane das v in oliver oder olive ist
schwierig auszusprechen
deshalb habe ich den einheimischen
gesagt nennt mich olli und sie haben
volley gesagt da kommt mein spitzname
her
nun ist volley wieder glücklich zu hause
zu sein nun ist er kein soldat hier ist
er wieder vater und keine story
der berühmteste sniper der welt
getroffen hat in unserer s cosmo nennt
herbert bauernebel uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ein wirklich herbert muss
man sagen ihrer typ der zwischen zwei
welten erlebt auf der einen seite kriege
und das nicht zum ersten mal jetzt muss
man mal schauen ob er herbert noch mal
ran kriegen ich glaube da ist gerade die
verbindung abgebrochen auf der einen
seite krieg da ist er wieder auf der
einen seite dieser krieg und auf der
anderen seite volley dieser kanadier der
in dieser hütte sitzt und offenbar auch
familie hat beschreibt und so einmal
herbert wie es war diesen menschen zu
treffen und wie das funktioniert jetzt
einfach in kanada in der hütte
weiterzumachen und was vor allem auch
eventuelle frauen kinder dazu sagen
ja dann kann man sich jetzt nicht
vorstellen wie eine so eine typische
kriegsmaschine einen clip kämpfer wie
man sie die man ihn kennt aus hollywood
filmen oder sowohl ist ein durchaus ein
normaler ein sehr sympathischer ein sehr
intelligenter belesener mann der eben
sich auf die fahnen geheftet hat der
ukraine helfen zu wollen er sagt der
ganz klar er das wasser kam ist das
kämpfen er ist ein guter sniper auch
wenn er sagt er ist nicht der beste und
eben in dieser zeit hat die eu keine
seine hilfe benötigt und deshalb habe er
sich entschlossen dort hinzugehen das
ganze war natürlich schwierig denn wie
gesagt er hat zu hause in quebec eine
verlobte und einen einjährigen sohn und
das war natürlich schwierig ich hatte
auch die chance mit seiner verlobten zu
sprechen die aus ihrer sicht dargestellt
hat und ihr natürlich erzählt hat wie er
ihr dann gesagt hat er würde gerne in
den krieg gehen wie sie nach langem
überlegen sich entschlossen hat ihnen
doch gehen zu lassen weil sie wusste wie
wichtig ihm das ist aber auch natürlich
diese furchtbare momente als die
russische propaganda seinen tod gemeldet
hat und er an der front war unseren
handy abgegeben hat also nicht reagieren
konnte auch sichtbar seiner familie bei
seiner verlobten melden zu können all
das war ihm nicht möglich dass man hat
es tage gedauert bis er sich endlich
gemeldet hat und seine verlobte ist
natürlich da durch die hölle gegangen
ist haben journalisten angerufen die
gesagt haben was sagen sie zum tode
ihres mannes als solche szenen das war
natürlich schon eine schwierige
situation und ihr jetzt scheint er doch
sehr froh zu sein wieder zurückgekehrt
zu sein sein sohn hat einen einjährigen
geburtstag gefeiert mit ihm er hat in
ihnen die hände in die hände in die arme
genommen gedrückt und es waren eben
wichtig dass er jetzt wieder fahrbar
sein kann und nicht nur eine story und
das genau das hat er eben befürchtet
dass sollte er in der ukraine fallen
dass er für seinen sohn einfach nur eine
geschichte sein würde und das hat er
jetzt verhindern können erstens aufgrund
der tatsache dass überlebt hat und dass
er sich entschlossen hat jetzt doch
zurück zu kehren zu seiner familie
sie beruflich weiter jetzt ist er in
kanada wie sie da sein alltag aus plante
wieder in den krieg zurück zu gehen
es ist erstaunlich dieser mann der eben
dem der mit dem mythos nachgesagt wird
der beste sniper der welt zu sein ist in
wirklichkeit ein ganz normaler computer
programmierer im zivilberuf lebt eben
wie gesagt in quebec er hat ein haus war
es mit seiner familie erlebt er hat sich
eine holzhütte gebaut im wald ganz
alleine dort hat er uns zum interview
empfangen all das ist ein ganz normales
leben und er erlebt sich hier eben ein
wieder natürlich wenn man mit ihm
spricht hört man schon heraus ja gerne
wieder zurückgehen würde dass er sagt
die ukraine braucht nach wie vor seine
hilfe man spürt ganz deutlich dass er
zurückgekehrt in der heimat schon wieder
lust hat zurückzugehen in den krieg auf
seine verlobte da jetzt noch mal
mitspielen wird ist eine
andere frage aber natürlich beobachtete
er das kriegsgeschehen und was
eigentlich auch erstaunlich ist daneben
dass er geschichtlich sehr belesen ist
dass er praktisch fast ein kleiner
historischer ist in sachen krieg dass er
den krieg sehr gut beschreiben kann auch
das macht ihn zu einer derartig
wichtigen persönlichkeit einfach seine
gabe geschichten zu erzählen in den
krieg hinein zu führen und der auch
deshalb ist er wahrscheinlich rund um
die welt zur medien sensation geworden
bauernebel wer den berühmtesten sniper
der welt getroffen hat vielen herzlichen
dank dir herbert